bien alors commencez par vous évidemment
françois mitterrand l'abeille et
l'architecte c'est vrai les prix ce
titre dans une phrase de marx d'abord
j'ai beaucoup comme d'habitude hésiter
je pense que chacun fait comme moi avant
de sauver un titre en fait moi je le
trouve que longtemps après avoir écrit
le livre et là je ne trouvais pas celui
ce titre excellent bien qui me fut venu
à l'esprit parce que j'avais déjà écrit
la prayelle grincer sorte de répétition
malgré tout ça m'avait frappé je n'ai
pas tiré d arguin marche de mon capital
cette citation spy hunter pas une
citation parlant lors d'un voyage en
crète que je rapporte dans ce livre avec
roger garaudy il m'incitait cette phrase
de mars qui dit à peu près je le cite de
mémoire
l'abeille la plus experte fera toujours
la même cellule dans la ruche
l'architecte le plus médiocre lui pour
un composé dans sa tête la cellule avant
de la construire et sera capable
c'est la suite du texte sera capable
d'innover d'imaginer et cette sorte de
balancement de comparaison entre la loi
de la nécessité la bei et la loi de
l'initiative mais médiocre est le même
qui suppose de la richesse de la vie
l'architecte a perdu assez bien raconté
ce que j'avais envie de dire si pourtant
que je veux référence à max prado d'un
coup une sorte de force et théoriques
que je ne récuse absolument pas oui
voilà qu'il m'aimait je veux je vous
raconte l'histoire c'est comme cela que
j'ai aussitôt raccourci ça assez comme
ça une sorte de clark dans leur esprit
je cherchais un tic sont le pain la bei
l'architecte l'abeille l'architecte moi
c'est comme ça que c'est pas pour autant
que l'on vous ranger parmi les autos
marxiste je crois qu'un drame
assisterait de la peine à me reconnaître
comme tel un vrai marxiste bon quels
sont les vrais marxiste de ceux qui
se pose en grand prêtre d'une religion
économique d'une philosophie dogmatique
le trahissent mars se sont pourtant ceux
qui s'expriment généralement au moment
du marxisme si bien que j'aurai un peu
tendance à ne pas admettre leur verdict
à tous leur jugement
mais cependant très simplement et avec
vérité je suis quelqu'un qui lit qui
cherche à comprendre
je pense que mars a joué le rôle
déterminant parmi ceux qui au cours de
ces 150 dernières années ont conduit les
idées du temps je pense qu'il en reste
beaucoup que chacun d'entre nous doit
méditer pour conduire sa propre vie
politique expliqué la société de son
temps mais comme je serais tenté d'en
rejeter certains aspects je suis donc
pas quelqu'un que l'on pourrait ranger
parmi les sectateurs ou parmi les
thuriféraires de mars
bon cet ouvrage bien que c'est la suite
de la paille et le grain parce que c'est
aussi une chronique et sous la cour les
années suivantes c'est à dire 75,78 j'ai
déjà expliqué l'autre fois je vais le
reprendre le thème chronique mis par
l'éditeur sage est acceptée puisque
c'est là ne recouvre pas tout à fait ce
que je veux dire
pourquoi parce que je suis un homme
politique est cet homme politique s'il
parle d'événements
il n'est pas possible c'est les crises
chroniques qui n'en oublie ou alors on
le prendra pour indice très négligents
offre volontairement il est très
important événement pense particulier à
la visite de de sadate à jérusalem dans
une balle pourtant un événement qui m'a
passionné dont je parlerai un jour ou
l'autre mais je ne veux pas m'imposer
cette obligation de semaine en semaine
d'écrire sur tel événement considéré par
la presse ou qui sera peut être
considérée par l'histoire comme
événement majeur de ce temps j'écris
quand j'ai envie d'écrire sur le sujet
qui sur le moment mais ce pire étant
entendu que je rejette temps à autres
les sujets les plus importants ou qui me
passionne le plus parce que je me dis un
jour j'écrirai mieux et plus
sérieusement sur ce sujet ça présente un
risque c'est un peu comme la
correspondance
quand je reçois pas mal de lettres
naturellement dans
le responsabilités qui sont les miennes
je reçois beaucoup de lettres et qu'elle
connaisse qui me fera beaucoup qui je
trouve très intéressante qui exige
réponse alors par la réponse sur
monsieur ou sur madame vous avez bien
voulu
j'ai l'honneur deux accusés de réception
résultat c'est que les accusés de
réception il arrive mais la lettre de
fond elle arrive pas parce que je me
disais je l'écrirai la semaine prochaine
et puis six mois après je retrouve la
lettre je m'aperçois que finalement la
chose importante je n'ai pas fait un
symbole souvent l'existence mais reste
donc au fond c'est l'éditeur qu'à me
souviens qu'on dit parce que je trouve
la centrale
et c'est pas un calice pas non plus un
journal parce que d'un journal et de
journal intime j'aurais aimé lui même et
les événements de ma vie privée dont je
parle sorte oui alors voilà c'est un peu
entre les deux mais je suis étonné par
238 comme ça je me méfie de la chronique
ce genre qui n'en est pas un le chemin
du journalisme et littérature celui qui
s'y adonnent me fait penser cours de 400
mètres cette fausse distance olympique
qu'on appelle sur les stades de ce prime
plomb ni soufre prix entre le besoin
d'aller vite et de garder le souffle
l'air vous manque le plus souvent l'air
- pas alors je veux dire simplement que
la chronique présente sur le plan
littéraire l'énorme danger de s'en tenir
un seul site où un solide et sans aucun
prolongement et qu'un livre composé de
chroniques risquent d'être le genre
mineur parce que ne permettant à aucun
moment à l'écrivain d'aller au bout de
son propos et il finit par créer une
sorte d'habitude qui risque de couper le
souffle dès lors que le même écrivain
souhaiterait écrire un livre d'un seul
mouvement de la première à quatre
centièmes page il ya donc dans ce type
de livre une sorte de facilité
redoutable alors tout le monde sait que
vous aviez en politique ils
reconnaissent aussi que vous écrivez
très bien mais j'étais j'ai eu la
curiosité de mettre le nez dans des
ouvrages assez ancienne vous notamment
sur la chine 12 ans et je me suis aperçu
que vous écrivez de mieux en eut
récemment pourquoi est ce que vous
faites davantage attention maintenant ce
que vous ratures et plus
qu'est-ce qu'il abhorre et écrire bien
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ensuite
ensuite boersch j'accepte mon papa son
et on peut pas se lancer dans une
discussion incident ensuite l'objectif
de mieux en mieux il dit mais c'est je
consacre enfin enfin je pense que si
c'est vrai c'est peut-être vrai c'est
parce que je suis de plus en plus libre
pendant longtemps et sur le plan de
l'écriture je t'ai je m'explique à un
moment donné comme quelqu'un qui écrit
tandis que derrière son dos le
professeur ou le critique littéraire pas
tout de suite mettre le doigt sur la
quasi erreurs de français sur la
mauvaise tournure
ce sentiment de quelqu'un d'examiner me
glace était peut-être d'ailleurs de
mogari mal placé mais beaucoup plus sur
le plan de ma pensée ce que j'ai envie
de dire où d'écrire je me sens beaucoup
plus libre à compter du moment où
j'écris ce que j'ai envie d'écrire sans
tenir compte de la bienséance ou des
intérêts généraux dont gestion je suis
seul juge
à partir de là je pense que ce que
j'écris sans ressasser plus libre des
banques sont plus libres c'est meilleur
puisqu'ils vous un père et fils me dit
aussi dans l'angoissé l'économie du mou
et vous ajoutez pages sont 110 vies je
suis reste de ma province mon écriture
s'en ressent que mon à un accent mais je
crois que je ne suis pas un amateur de
bavardages et j'ai une tendance s'est
pas absolument une règle il et
d'écrivains bavard ce compte qui
m'intéresse quand même
mais d'une façon générale dès lors que
je perçois que l'écrivain s'attarde au
lieu de dire ce qu'il a à dire dans la
langue de notre pays tel qu'on l'emploie
j'ai tendance à penser qu'ils s'évadent
et que ce n'est pas un très bon écrivain
je porte un jugement très sévère à
propos de quelqu'un qui a la réputation
d'un très grand écrivain précisément
parce que il est à mes yeux
naturellement que quelques d'éloquents
qui se croient tello candide en vidant
qui se croyait
20 kg est mort aujourd'hui et 10 ont
fait tout bonnement que j'applique seul
humain à malraux c'est qu'aussitôt ça
fait scandale nature alors d'autant plus
que je reconnais à malraux d'autres
immenses qualités mais oui c'est le
sentiment que toute une partie de
l'oeuvre cdc du remplissage quoi de
l'éloquence en région pour un homme
politique qui se méfie de l'éloquence
dans un livre écrit ça peut paraître
paradoxal mais c'est parce que j'ai
besoin moi même a constamment de même
gendarmes et autres mon propre
tempérament qui deviendrait vite
éloquent et écrire d'une façon éloquente
world at war a le don de m'exaspérer 6
mai que je m'exaspère moi même alors je
suis vigilant et ça devient peut-être
même à certains moments trop cursif
outre cours par souci disons de lutter
contre ce qui serait un défaut naturel
il vouera tuerait beaucoup j'ai failli
heurter question aux larges et des pages
d'admirer la vous devez souffrir ses
passes il écrit les pages admirables
mais je souffre toujours beau mais
qu'est-ce qu'il emprunte alors dans cet
acte décrit assez la souffrance où nous
irons nous ingérons regard c'est
difficile c'est dur je suis quelqu'un
qui devint la page d'écriture tirer la
langue lui prêtent beaucoup attention
non tu tires pas la langue se passe pas
comme ça je pense pression photo
matthias moi je ne tirerai pas alors mes
jeux je suis très très très attentif je
suis très critique à l'égard de moi même
et je ne suis pas du tout que ce que
j'ai publié le contente absolument mais
s'il n'existe pas certain rythme
intérieur traduit par mon langage écrit
alors je ne publie pas rond donc ce que
ce qui est dans samonac or pour le mois
seulement parlons pas de moi et ma façon
d'écrire il est tellement de grands
écrivains qu'il mériterait mieux que moi
de s'exprimer à ce sujet diront plus que
vous posez la question aux responsables
je vous dis simplement que pour moi
écrire correspond à une nécessité
intérieure et si cela suppose beaucoup
de peine c'est à dire de souffrance de
peine intercalaires le résultat me plaît
j'aime écrire mais je perçois que ces
quatre professionnels de l'écriture sont
contents d'apprendre comment un amateurs
doués mais vous voyez pas bernard pivot